Oh Billy come on okay wait for it come
on
wait for it Oh
okay fine Hey reset Mon
are you ready for crow Spring Break
Spring Break Daytona basketball court
sports peaceful water sport Oh shake em
up shake em up cocktail Tom Cruise shake
him up shake him up Taku they're hot
who's there coconut shake it out with
you time not much that's how it was
listed whoa Oh party oh we gotta stay on
the board
my buddy boy or girl whoa I never
thought I would say this but can we not
drink and can we do your chores what is
happening to you tea aah Oh guys I'm
sorry Ricky why are you taking pictures
of us probably first time time I'm not
taking pics of you guys I'm using my
spring break to photograph the theatre
for the school newspaper Wow
and I don't masturbate never got into it
by here's the definition of an enigma
- way too loud remember that band enigma
no okay I don't know what that is
Ricky that you like yeah why are you
taking our suitcase up the TV that's why
you don't see fun but they still want to
be